okay this is a really great opportunity
to support some awesome musicians in our
audience
JDI ker is a musician who is a big fan
of the David Pakman show his drummer
Dylan has been a member for years also a
really great supporter of the show and
JDI ker is a singer-songwriter out of
Youngstown Ohio and I actually know a
little bit about Youngstown Ohio because
one of our earliest radio affiliates is
located in Youngstown and Youngstown is
to put it lightly an economically
ravaged place in the United States and
Youngstown has been supporting our show
for a really long time by broadcasting
it on one of the local radio stations
and JDI Kerr has a new song out called
the money back which is about the Trump
era and about sort of not allowing this
new era of politics to be normalized
which we're gonna listen to a little bit
of now while we talk about it
so anyway JD got in touch and he and
Dylan who's a member and his band are
touring Europe right now they've been
listening to the show on the road they
wanted to sponsor some memberships and
have me mention their new songs so what
they're doing is sponsoring eight half
priced memberships they've already paid
for half of the normal cost of
memberships which is $60 for eight
people so if you want one of these eight
half-price memberships you just pay the
other $30 you end up getting a 50%
discount and in order to take advantage
of those just get in touch with me david
at david pakman.com or use the contact
form on our website
but either way please check out JD Iker
saw money back on Spotify this helps
them out they're helping us out which is
awesome add the track to your playlists
check out the entire album called the
compass EP but again they're sponsoring
eight half-price memberships if you want
one of those at half price get in touch
with me directly which you can do using
the contact form at david pakman.com or
just email me david at david pakman.com
i'll be your person
membership concierge say I want one of
those JDI ker half-price memberships and
I'll send you a code first come first
serve as usual so I would jump on it I
would anticipate these aren't going to
last too long
thanks again the JDI ker